all right whenever you're ready  we are shooting a documentary because i  am about to meet my first biological  relative  she's amish i'm not i am not  we are humbled and grateful to have our  sister margot return to us  i've always hoped that i could meet you  all so this is a really special moment  for me  hey  mind if i film you for a moment  [Music]  hey  [Music]  i like your doll  what's her name  yeah you know that was my mom's name  she used to live here a long time ago  she's still here  [Music]  what did she say  [Music]  whoa  why would they build a church all the  way back here  what is that the demon asmodeus was  trapped inside a chosen woman of god  this has happened before  what the hell  are these from my mom  you can't have me and my baby  i know everybody's family within a  50-mile area  they ain't amish  [Music]  [Music]  is  [Music]  oh my god are you sure about this  i have to know  [Music]  [Music]